I think it was about a year ago at this
time when we were talking about
Christian Hackenberg maybe a top 10 pick
maybe the number one quarterback taken
and now we're talking about other
quarterbacks going in the first round
former Penn State quarterback Christian
Hackenberg joining us on the program
good morning Christian how are you I'm
good thanks I mean how was the Jon
Gruden camp that was a great experience
she's being able to get down there and
kind of chop it up with coach on the
board a little bit and go over some film
really enjoyed it and super super good
experience for me and then very valuable
throughout this process how goofy is he
yeah he's great great personalities me
not hard to not hard to get along with
you get in there and and starts to
starts cracking some jokes and gets rid
of the flow of things you I I really
enjoyed it my type of dude yeah I really
really enjoyed time I spent down there
what's the one thing that Gruden told
you that is going to help you whether he
criticized you or complimented you yeah
I think it's just getting comfortable
that was his biggest thing is just being
comfortable um in in everything but
that's basically the big overlaying word
that he use let's just get back to being
comfortable again and I think that
that's something that's very correctable
so um I'm not that's weird what anything
just really excited about taking this
next step I how do we get here Christian
as I mentioned you know you were that
people are looking at you a year ago is
maybe the number one quarterback what
happened how do we get to maybe you're
not even a first-round draft pick yeah I
mean I think to diversity hits and at
the end of the day some people look at
it as a bad thing I really look at it as
valuable a thing I think an asset to my
game and it's only prepared me more to
make this step I know what I can do I
know I can play and I know that my
feeling is is really really high I'm
just scratching the surface of it and i
think you know just making sure i get in
a great situation go do what I do best
for my head down
are in the trusting team and the trust
of the coaches you know I'm excited
about so I really try not to listen to
what anyone else says you know I'm very
confident what I can do i know that i
could be a franchise quarterback and i'm
just making sure that every day i'm
taking steps towards doing so i'm just
waiting on the draft what do you do
better than Carson wins and jared golf
yeah i mean i'm not really into
comparing either you know i just really
focus on what i need to do i know i know
where i need to get better um and I know
that that it's obviously been pretty
good based upon what you were saying
about a year ago so I just know what I
need to do to continue to get better and
continue to focus on on what I need to
do um will let everything play out he's
Christian Hackenberg former Penn State
quarterback joining a Stan Patrick show
what's the one theme you found that
quarterbacks ask you in the interviewing
process is there one topic that these
coaches are asking you about yeah I mean
to be honest with you you know there's
there's been a bunch of questions but I
think really you know the overruling
thing was I think they really try to
know how much of all I really knew I
think that was big thing that that was
coming out of my whole college
experience having been under coach
O'Brien encode Franklin and having a
really good base and knowledge of the
game I think they really wanted to test
the limits of it so I got got a lot of
questions about Phil I'm talking ball
and to me that's a strength so kind of
played right into my strength and I feel
very confident about what i know and i
think i'm even more excited about what I
don't know and what I have to learn to
pick a to get better take me back to
when you were recruited at penn state
penn state's going through this turmoil
Joe Paterno has been fired bill
o'brien's in there and you had the
opportunity to leave and you stayed
loyal to Bill O'Brien did you give how
much thought that you give to leaving
penn state when they were going through
that turnover are you talking about when
i was in high school yet yeah when you
were being recruited yeah i think in
high school was a little bit no i'm not
saying there was a ton of thought I
didn't I was very committed to what I
was doing but I definitely went back and
i re-evaluated my decision with my
parents in my high school coach and at
the end of the day
you know nothing changed I stayed there
for a reason and it wasn't just a
knee-jerk reaction to decommit or stay
it was very thought out and I thank my
parents for that I think my high school
coach for that for being being very
supportive with me throughout the entire
process and making sure that I made the
best decision for me um and you know I
still feel that that that it was I'm
very thankful for them for my college
experience and both on and off the field
I cleared this report up by the
monday-morning quarterback Robert Clem
Co said that you blamed james franklin
your coach for your struggles your
sophomore and junior year said is that a
fair assessment of what was said by you
not at all um you know I basically went
into every interview and said you know
here's what we did and and the
overruling theme was that it was just
different and then I was very focused on
making sure that they knew that I was
very focused and in tune with making
sure that I was ready to take this step
to the next level so when I was in the
interviews I just basically said it was
different explain the differences and
continued to just be very focused on the
future and doing what I know I need to
do to be the best professional
quarterback that I can be how did he get
construed that way though Christian yeah
I'm not sure um baby should ask ride
yeah because it just feels that like
that would be something I would want to
know about if I'm a coach because we're
in it we're in it together and then if
you're actually coming out saying hey
look you know because of james franklin
i didn't i didn't play well it feels
like you're the one being slandered here
where you're you know throwing your
coach under the bus yeah I mean at the
end of the day I've never done it has
never been who I was I've never pointed
a finger I owned everything I put on
tapes and I made sure the coaches knew
that in the interviews and um yeah I I
know exactly what I need to get better
at and cooks wagon wasn't the one
pulling the trigger I was so I think
that just be an asinine statement for me
to go in there and say that so yeah I
know what I need to do and I know what I
said and if someone interpreted it that
way then that would be very shocking to
me so I'm very focused on on
on the future and moving on and getting
better who'd you will grow up following
what do you mean a team yeah yeah I
really didn't have one I mean I was born
north eastern PA lived there for a
couple years and then moved down to
central Virginia so um never really had
a team just follow players what
quarterback did you love growing up when
I was younger I love far I love watching
far play and then as I got older you had
the Aaron Rodgers and drew brees and the
Peyton Manning's and the Tom Brady's so
we've had a pretty good run of guys as I
was growing up so I've been fortunate to
watch that and it's pretty cool they
make it look pretty easy though
Christian sided out it's not that easy
not that at definitely where will you be
on draft day okay home my family my
brothers so it's gonna be nice do you
have any idea where you're going you
know what to tell me but you have any I
mean not really you know I've kind of
looked at it is making sure hopefully I
let in a really good situation and again
it's focused on the things that I have
control over I have no control where I'm
gonna go where I go but when i get their
ass control over how I work and and how
I prepare and how I present myself so I
think I think that's ultimately where
your head has to be and that's where it
is for me and I'm very very relaxed
going into this last week here I will
enjoy the Chicago Bears you'll love
Chicago Christian thank you all right
good luck thanks for joining us let's
see their Christian Hackenberg former
Penn State quarterback the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience